oh god oh god oh god this morning's
gonna be a sugar rush
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hey guys it's alvin i'm gonna be making
some crazy cheesecake tower today it's
kind of based off of this idea that's
been circling around the internet called
the chirp pumpel it's basically like a
three layered cake and each layer has a
different cake on the outside and
different pie flavor on the inside so
the word trepumple comes from
cherry pumpkin and apple which are the
pies that are inside all these three
different cakes i was just wondering
like is there a cheesecake version of
this that we can make that's my mission
today so we'll see how it goes alvin has
been explaining to me what this
chirpomple business is about and i still
don't get it so you want me to draw out
what i'm going to make yes because do
you understand what i just said at all i
think that what you're saying is there's
going to be cheesecake and there are
going to be layers i mean you know me
and layers man we go way back
[Music]
i need to think about what flavors i'm
going to pick vanilla and chocolate so
those are my two cheesecake flavors and
as far as the desserts that they're
gonna be wrapped in cheesecakes really
go well with brownie apple pie oh red
velvet's a good one i'm probably gonna
want two vanilla and one chocolate
chocolate does not go well with berry
red velvet maybe banana bread not apple
pie cinnamon roll is a little weird
cookie maybe but i think it has the most
natural synergy with brownie i'm gonna
pair the chocolate cheesecake with a
brownie on the outside i think cookie
dough and cheesecake is a really great
combination looking at the other flavors
honestly red velvet is a really good
solid option i'm gonna go with that
there's gonna be three layers i want the
top and the bottom to be vanilla the
middle one is going to be chocolate the
sturdiest item needs to go on the bottom
i feel like cookie is the sturdiest
thing making little chocolate black dots
that means red velvet has to be on the
top so the brownie has to go around here
in the middle call me picasso you know
this looks amazing it looks like a fancy
mattress a fancy mattress it's literally
all coming down to the layers it needs
to look like straight needs to look
perfect it needs to look clean that's
those are my standards and i really want
to make this happen but i want to make
it right let's make it happen
we run into major problems we can find
the bottom of what is it the springform
pan and if there's no bottom there's no
cheesecake
all right i'm just gonna bring out
everything we've got
nope nope nope
nope it's gonna be a no for me dawg this
doesn't work uh is this gonna open
man that's so little
oh wait it looks pretty good
oh cool nice we got it
[Music]
this is where the sexy music begins to
play
here comes the cheesecake yum yum yum
this is just normal brownie batter
one down
look at alvin's face of focus wow
amazing amazing
[Music]
oh that looks so cool what
you're the best type man ever brenda
there goes the focus space
yo this batter is like
mega thick like all caps greasies
spaces in between each one you know what
i mean now i have to do the cookie dough
one brenda oh my goodness i was waiting
for it can i get some help getting this
cookie dough into like a bowl oh my god
i get to help you build this crazy thing
all right that's good brenda don't worry
that's it that's great oh i thought i
was doing something a little more
special i wouldn't ask you with that
okay
all right cookie dough's going in it's
like an
ancient whale building that's pretty
cool you're watching the write history
channel i actually learned this
technique from my ancestors all right
seriously
back to the boy
[Music]
tuck them into bed
[Music]
all right so the third one is now in the
oven after they kind of bake off i'm
gonna check on them i'm gonna put them
back into the fridge they're gonna hold
a lot of heat they're gonna need a lot
of time to cool down tomorrow we're
gonna try to look into how we can
assemble it i really want it to look
like this see you guys tomorrow
hey guys it's day two i'm gonna check on
the cheesecakes that i put in the
freezer to see how they've said
hopefully it still looks like this
picture let's go check it out all right
brenda i got a i got some good news and
i got some bad news okay so the bad news
is
the red velvet one it somehow it didn't
rise enough or
it rose and just deflated all the way if
i cut into it's kind of it's going to
look like that and that's going to be a
no for me dog okay this one's looked
pretty good yeah so the brownie one
looks pretty good i think what i'm going
to do is i'm going to try to get the
cake batter as close to the consistency
of brownie batter as possible if you see
the bottom here like that's really cool
i want the top to look like that so
that's why i'm gonna do it again
i don't know if you can see this but the
batter is a lot different than last time
it's a lot thicker do i dare say
thick
the bat or something got me working out
batter's in i'm gonna give it one more
shot put it back in the oven and
hopefully it just really stays
flat i hope it stays level i really need
this to sort of like be flat or else
this is going to be another
retry
okay
oh look at this yeah it's like it's
pretty good i think this is good to go
oh god oh god oh god
[Music]
i think if we're doing cheesecakes kind
of makes sense to like do some cream
cheese frosting so
i've got my little bad boy better not
wobble on me bertha come on
this is so cool it does all the work for
me i don't freaking stir forever
you guys know how much sugar frosting
has in it because it's a lot
yo i need to record this for my mixtape
yeah we're in the studio here at tasty
trying to pull out something crazy i
don't know how long this is going to
take but i'm just icing on that cake
okay guys we're gonna go and assemble
the cake now probably the scariest part
with three layers are super heavy and
hopefully this frosting is thick enough
to glue the layers together as well as
make it smooth on the outside it's going
to be kind of tough but here we go
it's the cake the ring come on
lots of focus here pressure's on i guess
god damn
[Music]
gorgeous i hope it's enough i really
don't want to make more maybe if i stop
eating oh my god no wonder
you know chocolate ganache drip on top
throw some
nice chopped chocolate chunks around the
bottom rim of the cake
you and your layer love my layers brenda
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm gonna call this big boy i'm gonna
call it bub b-u-b-b
oh it's a heavy boy bub why are you
gonna be so big
please left with your core yes ma'am
bend your knees
it's here houston the eagle has landed
that looks real it is real
woohoo that was close
we go
oh my god
yes
only halfway there let's keep going come
on oh it's a heart attack
come on let's go cut this boy
okay
okay
all right i feel like i'm through
[Music]
gotta say
turned out a lot better than i thought
it was i'm pretty proud of this i think
it's
it's kind of this crazy idea that i had
that i was kind of able to make into
reality i'm pretty happy with it i hope
i can feed a lot of people with this the
layers came out but i really want to
know if it's actually going to taste
good so i hope these people like it
because if it looks good but doesn't
taste good then we didn't win brenda
i love cookie dough
that was nice this is very chocolatey
i like it i like having all the
different flavors together
wow
good is not even the word
i like the fact it's real cheesecake
right like it's the fake cheesecake he's
done it again
really feels good when i able to like
make a food sort of idea or a food dream
like into reality i love the way people
can smile when you feed them
it also took a lot of restraint for me
not to play mixtapes during the entire
process because i knew i had to keep the
cake cold and if i played it would have
just melted so
hey brenda you wanted final thoughts i'm
giving you honest thoughts straight from
the heart
[Music]
da
[Music]